dans un appel téléphonique à non samedi
soir n'ai pas reçu un appel téléphonique
non nature ah bah oui ça devait pas reçu
un appel de quelqu'un qui est voulais
vous parler un agent à nos gamins qui
m'a appelé qui m'a dit est ce que vous
êtes gilles verdez ouais alors j'ai dit
bah non je suis désolé j'ai raccroché
et vous
[Rires]
c'était un travail sur the voice et il
ya un type qui décroche que n'est pas le
numéro jusqu'au bout 3g je décroche dit
vous êtes gilles verdez j'ai dit bah non
je suis désolé vous trompez numéro j'ai
raccroché
c'était en fait je vous explique doug
edwards gt gt avec ramzy et un malik
bentalha et on voulait il voulait vous
appelez en fait j'ai laissé un moment je
leur ai dit c'est votre numéro et en
fait ramzy voulez vous appelez se faire
passer pour joey starr et dire à l'eau
thierry halo johnny logis leverdez
savais que c'était vous vous alliez d'y
renoncer thierry moreau a en plus tu
veux faire passer pour gilles verdez on
va débuter voilà ça n'a pas fonctionné
la tristesse du scénario et enfin bon je
vous raconte tout et donc il a créé il
arrivait pas faire là bas donc il a fait
oui bonjour c'est jean-pierre finul
force et voilà ému lui a raccroché
direct à la gueule par la merci donc je
voulais vous le dire c'était moi